hey everybody last week of my tour
before I filmed my special in Chicago at
the Vic theater December 1st and 2nd
tickets are still available right now
for that you can get them on salcano
comedy.com this is the last week I'm
performing this material tonight we're
in Appleton everybody how'd you guys
like the show
[Music]
tonight
glit
tomorrow I am in the daa Beach Improv
it's going to be great down in Fort
laale Florida tomorrow Friday and then
shows on Saturday and then the following
week we are in New Haven Connecticut
Thursday Providence Rhode Island Friday
Medford Massachusetts Saturday all those
shows are almost sold out then we have
Phoenix Arizona December uh 2 uh
December 1st and 2nd at Friday Saturday
Phoenix Arizona um back at the um
standup live which is a great venue um
I've been there a couple of times before
but I'm doing my brand new hour going to
do a bunch of got some crowd work got
some new bits you haven't heard so go
check it out and then Salt Lake City and
Denver all those shows are sold out and
then we added The Wil turn theater in
Los Angeles and a show in San Diego in
January Chris D comedy.com for tickets
I'm really proud of this hour so come
have fun and love your life quick tour
dates are on sale right now at salvano
comedy.com there's a big Illinois run in
November leading up to my comedy special
at the Vic in Chicago on December 1st
and second the second sold out as you
guys I hopefully know uh and so we edit
two shows on the first all will be taped
and all if you have a ticket to any of
those shows you'll be eligible to win uh
a flight hotel and trip to the set of
Impractical Jokers I'm choosing one
ticket out of those four shows uh
December 1st is still on sale right now
but it's going fast savano comedy.com
hope to see you guys on the
road don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
hey bab hey bab hey bab hey bab all
right babes we are back uh continu there
was as you coined did a piss hanger from
last week and you have a vom story maybe
even a piss story here too there's a lot
of them so let's just let's just toss
around the Hot Potato what was the last
time you played Hot Potato I mean I
don't know I think I might have played
it like at a adult party with like beer
or something like that yeah I think so
too drinking something yeah something
hot potato hot potato and musical chairs
are kind of cut from the same thing
musical chairs is even worse because
there's a lot more physicality and and
there's a lot more risk that you end up
on your ass right musical chairs kid the
games that they had us play when we kids
were anxiety inducing dude I IAL cuz you
felt like well it's all about being left
out yeah you you attach yourself to
being like you know like yeah you're
you're out now go do you know what I
feel for kids because they stopped it
because some kid broke his arm but like
dodgeball I mean I used to who they
stopped the gym teachers in our school
so I thought you meant like it the
people of Earth came together
nobody I think it may have been a
Statewide ban of New York at some point
like because we had to stop pretty St
like immediately the idea is to assault
yeah and we were just piping undiagnosed
autistic kids back then because they
didn't diagnos I mean like off the side
of their heads what happens is the the
the already the kids that were already
not that athletic week or what they're
they're the they're the gazel chum did
you have did you guys play suicide in
school yeah uh yeah yeah ran I did it in
real life no I played as I did it
like which landan therapy um throw it
against throw the ball against the wall
and if you catch if you drop it though
you have to run and touch the wall and
if you don't touch the wall we're just
drilling they let they let us play that
in school buts up but Up bouncy ball oh
up that well that was at the end though
oh oh no if you threw it and and you
about you got to run to the wall and if
you touched the wall you they could wing
it at you but if they touch it you're
good but then I forget why what what
occurrence would have you go up and just
stand as back if they hit the wall if
the ball hits the wall before you get to
the wall you have to stand at the wall
like firing style and if they drill you
you're back in that's how we used to
play what happens if your ass is up and
they throw the ball what' you say this
Filipino girl pushed me down and fifth
grade when I went up and I loved her and
I went up for like a you know whatever
and she shoved me and I just landed on
my elbows and just had complete tire
marks on my elbows for like three weeks
and I had to be like it's
cool that's what they say don't don't
play anything too competitive with
Filipinos uh especially who can wear the
best color
contacts so we what happens if your ass
is up on the wall and then they throw it
to miss you that you that's it they they
they miss their opportunity you come
back go back and if you if you okay and
so it's also if you go to catch it and
you miss it you run and if you catch it
the other person runs so every time
someone's getting assault someone's
getting assault yeah and you want to
know what's weird too we also had a soda
called suicide where it was you every
single type of soda was called a suicide
so like if I don't know why but at
baseball I'm thinking about this right
now how many things were called suicide
when I was a kid cuz like after weird
after games we would go to the snack bar
at mono field and you'd get a suicide
and it was a cup with orange soda grape
soda root beer Coke Sprite Allin one and
you just gunned it and that was called
the Su called a jersey ter no kidding a
dirty Turn Pipe a jersey turn Jersey
Turn Pipe I like that you guys do that I
don't think we did do that I did that
with like ices at the movie theater but
that was on my own
valtion you had no idea yeah no idea
weird that we we called stuff that like
we had to run now they call them up
Downs in basketball and stuff when you
free throw back back free throw they
called that though I think it was cuz it
was so hard you wanted to kill yourself
after no it wasn't 100% suicides yeah
yeah yeah but the ball with the tennis
ball against the wall that you oh no
that was cuz you you look like an idiot
in front of your class so you want to
kill yourself gruesome name reflects the
gruesome name reflects the intensity of
the physical effort it requires that's a
m i don't understand there's no need to
everything was called also coaches I
don't know about you guys growing up but
coaches love to like threaten violence
on us and like you know even like
violence that we would inflict on each
other it wasn't even that they would do
it's like oh you guys don't want to do
that cool we're doing I forget what that
I played football one season but that
one drill where you lay head-to-head on
your back and then you get up and you
both there's a ball carrier and
then they do it on the beach at like
spring breaking out and it's always ends
with somebody getting paralyzed yeah
insane but we say that was a punishment
or a fun drill depending on how you
looked at it but for somebody my size I
looked at it as a punishment and he'd
line me up with like a linebacker and
I'd get annihilated yeah was that's wild
dude oh I just realized something if
you're watching this week and you didn't
see last week's we just we we rolled in
from last week to this week this is a
double header this is our friends and
hysterical comedians Mike Cannon Mike
fya Chris is moving still and uh so
we're just kind of they're they're
hopping in forr today um yeah we left on
a piss hanger because I was saying that
one time I got pissed on uh and I didn't
ask for that uh and I yeah how old were
you when this happened it was it was my
young 20s and I was I went to Atlantic
City for the night uh to um to go to a
club and uh and I there's there's a
reason why I say that I think I took
ecstasy this night now I don't really
condone it I don't do it anymore I
actually would say these days it's
terrifying especially with all the stuff
no way don't condone it don't do it if
you're a kid listening it's the worst
thing in the world don't do it at all
terrible this was 20 plus years ago um
when it was
awesome yeah when everything I said
didn't apply at all back when it was
pure rap poison it's always I look back
and I go thank God that I wasn't the
person that became a statistic for real
okay so don't do it stay from all I uh
so I did it in this we were waiting for
it to kick in you know and you know me
and my friends are there and it's this
nightclub in Atlantic City and I go up
to the bar and I'm alone I go up to the
bar alone and there's two girls next to
me this is a time when actually it was
very invogue and a lot of the people in
the nightclubs were doing it and so it
was like a very um people would talk to
each other it wasn't like anything like
you know what I mean well you might have
a little nerves to go up to someone of
course yeah it was not it was not like
that people were
like nobody was looking at their phones
so you were almost in yourage
pacifiers while on ecstasy and
[__]
pafs sticks I remember coming to my
friend's apartment at like 4:00 a.m. and
she answered the door with her eyes like
this and she was in roller skates and I
was like all right yeah let's go H yeah
party time roll a skate around your own
house it's amazing I'm G to do that man
I'll mess up the floors we'll figure it
out
uh I'm at the bar yeah two girls are
next to me and we start chatting cuz we
wait we're all waiting for a drink and
they're nice and we're talking and I and
I I I don't know if we talked about if
we were on cuz the thing is you would
you know when someone else is on it and
there's kind of a you you're Bond over
that because it's like the goddamn fish
concert right so so we're talking and
they're like oh yeah we did because it
was like did it kick in like did yours
kick in yet they like oh mine kicked in
I'm like oh mine didn't kick in yet
we're waiting to get
waters and uh and then all of a
sudden I feel a warm sense
ation on my
legs and I was like oh and I'm like wait
is it this in my head then it's like
warmer and warmer and then it's like
undeniable I'm like I think it's kicking
in and they're like yeah I go yeah I
feel it I feel like kicking in like my
legs are warm or whatever and we're
waiting and I
turn and there is a drunk guy so drunk
guy probably doesn't even know where he
is standing not even a like foot and a
half behind me whatever and he's swaying
his is out and he's pissing on my
legs it was piss bro it wasn't anything
but piss I turned around I was in such
shock oh oh no no that's what happened
too they said we feel it too that's why
I was that's why I was like wait how
could you feel it like are
I are you two my
soulmates you have to watch the last
episode I'm not going to go back in uh
it's a reference no yeah I was like oh I
think I am starting to feel cuz my legs
feel warm they're like yeah and I was
like yeah and like yeah like how's that
even like and then we we all turned and
this kid is he's literally like this and
he's pissing and I was so shocked this
is a regular business establishment and
he his dick is out and he's pissing
right and
they screamed so loud that over the the
system of the thing the bouncers saw
something was happening and his friends
saw and ran and grabbed him and started
running through the uh through the dance
floor like it was almost like a scene
from like John Wick like you know like
the lights were flashing they were
trying to dodge us it's like you hear
the Techno music and we like no and
we're running after him the perfect
piss and now I'm like that I was so mad
cuz I was there for the night only and I
wasn't going home it's a 2hour drive I
didn't even drive so
the pissed pants are staying on me oh my
God where on the leg did he get you
Knees Down KNE down KNE
down makes the whole leg no and and it
was so much voled your brain if it was a
woman like maybe I'm like you know what
it is leg up on the bar I don't she
doesn't she doesn't repel me you know
like it is what it is Love Is Love so uh
but it was so much so that I remember
that my pant legs was sticking to my
skin
yeah so so we're running after this guy
and I'm like I I don't know what I'm
going to do really uh he's a bigger a
bigger guy but his but he knew he was so
drunk he would have just fell down and
his friends are and we're running after
him and at this moment I'm adrenaline is
kicking and um I think it looked like a
big commotion and so the security
started running down and they got to
like almost the door or or or they were
going somewhere I don't know they were
going to try and hide I don't remember
exactly and security guard stops us all
cuz we would like about to catch up to
and then they like grabbed us all and
like what's going on what's going
they're like this [__] and he peed
on us you know and the guy just was
like it's the spirit of
him that was I mean that's crazy that
like naked man touch my SK I didn't want
to say anything I don't even know where
this was had those piss
man they grabbed this guy and they threw
him out the door fine yeah some justice
but the you're in room still doesn't dry
your pants you should have just taken
his
pants know right just beat him once and
then take this is what I had to do and
this is a night where I even know that
the after Club is even happening oh yeah
so I had to make peace with it so I went
to the bar I bought a couple of bottles
of water and then I dumped full bottles
of water on both legs now okay was all
the piss out no that dilution percentage
better than what it was but now my pants
are SU popping wet so also the sensation
of the water it doesn't it still feels
like the piss is connected to my legs I
got to know I got this is early 2000s
what kind of pants are you wearing
terrible pants I was in club pants okay
this was all black like polyester like
you know the dress pants you got in the
mall at like the club store cook Comedy
Central presents pants exactly exactly
that like yeah we used to have a store
in the mall called bang bang and it was
in the St and that's where everyone got
their club outfits back in the day you'd
literally go there and see everyone
getting their outfits for the weekends
and and you even if you even saw your
friends and be like bangang yeah bang
bang bang bang it was it was just and
there was another one called
merrygoround and those were where you
got your Club clothes and that was that
so you know sometimes you'd see yourself
in the same shirt as somebody uh but
they were so embarrassing if I put them
on now if I had them today we would have
tears in our eyes with the fashion
choice of this thing they would kind of
widel legged you know and then I wore a
black dress shoe with it and probably a
black dress shirt too right it was
either it was a button down or something
it was that everybody looked like
Christoph you had to have a to get in
Terri it was a terrible time for fashion
in general and for myself and now it's
back now people and colog the [__] up no
I can't do cologne I get nauseous and
throw up and I get a headache so I can't
do cologne I would have swore you were
an aqua deio guy well well okay back in
like high
school I had in high school I had like
six or seven colognes I weaned myself
down to one and then one day I guess I
just couldn't take it anymore and I
stopped buying it and I and I can't even
be with anyone that that has I mean like
as a partner or like my girlfriend but I
also like
if some of these women they they they
they I don't know what they do but if
I'm sitting in a restaurant table next
to me ICI or even in an elevator but a
plane ride dude I swear to God I have to
like just like with my friend I puked on
I have to hold in the and I get a
splitting headache I guess I must be
allergic to something I have some type
of sensitivity anyway where was I going
with this uh your Club pants you poured
water all over your Club pants and you
knew that they were but yeah I had to
just the rest the whole night once it
kicked in were you okay did you make
peace with it babe I want to talk to you
about beam dream powder did you know
that poor sleep can cause weight gain
mood issues poor mental health and lower
productivity I didn't and now I do I'm
fat and Moody but not anymore because
I've been taking beam dream powder sleep
is the foundation of our mental and
physical health and performance in our
days having a consistent nighttime
routine is nonnegotiable and today my
listeners get a special discount on
beams dream powder it's actually
excellent I've had it South talked about
it the cocoa flavored is unbelievable
it's like it tastes it's like one of the
best hot chocolates you'll ever have and
it helps you sleep so today my listeners
get a special discount on beam's dream
powder they're bestselling healthy hot
cocoa for sleep with no added sugar now
available in delicious seasonal flavors
like cinnamon cowcow uh sea salt caramel
and white chocolate peppermint better
sleep has never tasted better a recent
clinical study revealed dream help 93%
of users wake up feeling more refreshed
and 93% reported that dream helped them
get a more restful night's sleep if you
want to try beams best-selling dream
powder take advantage of their biggest
sale of the year and get up to 50% off
for a limited time when you go to shop
beam.com heyab the discount is auto
applied at checkout no code necessary
that's shop
beam.com for up to 50% off go beam it
this episode is sponsored by Blue CH
Let's Talk About Sex guys do you
remember the days when you were always
ready to go now you can increase your
performance and get that extra conf
confence in bed listen up baby it is
blue.com blue is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra seis and Levitra
but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost blue chew tablets
are made right here in the USA and
prepared and shipped direct to your door
in a discret package the best part it is
all done online so no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
the process is simple sign up right now
at blue.com consult with their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within Days Blue wants to
help you have better sex discover your
options at bluechew.com chew it and do
it baby and we have got a special deal
for our listeners try bluechew free when
you use our promo code hey bab at
checkout just pay $5 shipping that's
blue.com promo code heyab to receive
your first month free visit blue.com for
more details and important safety
information and we thank blue for
sponsoring this podcast baby go get hard
I think it kind of hindered me a little
bit well also the the adrenaline can
kind of cut through drug I think it
hindered me um I I I don't really much
remember the rest of the night you
started breathing very heavily through
your nose you're just like I got to a
fight on ecstasy once in a bar in this
place Brook cell's and nyak that used to
routinely serve underage kids pretty
sure I was underage at the time my
friend Ryan uh got into we got into
fights every weekend in this one strip
on Main Street it because how much of
that was your fault a fair amount but
but not all of it it wasn't like you
went out and it was people always
starting okay no yes it was but we also
weren't opposed to fighting so it was
that it was we were trying to get laid
as as young men do and we all second
best as a fight like that's kind that's
kind of what it was yeah it sucked it
was a shitty period of of my anger that
I was just going out but we took I never
understood that no it's a terrible
mindset uh we we took these uh press
pills that are triple stacks and we uh
so it's like three basically ecstasy
pills in one it was really really strong
and whatever and we're in this in this
bar and we're having a good time
something happens there's a commotion I
see my friend Ryan get kind of rushed
out of the bar and all my other friends
are like you know tweaking their own
nipples they're not really paying
attention so I ran out there and my
friend Ryan like the kid immediately
took off his shirt he like threw it at
me for I grabbed it and like rubbed my
face with it
immediately like threw a punch at this
kid and all of a sudden I'm like on
ecstasy and I am the best boxer I've
ever
been every move in your head no in real
life in like every fiber of my body you
kind of locked in in a way dude I was
reading his moves I mean Grant he was
probably shitfaced but I'm just like I'm
Neo in The Matrix moving so fast it's
slow dude drugs are so great in that way
that they make you get out of your own
way and you literally like harness all
of your potential that's the double EDG
that's the double play that at a middle
school yeah disclaimer no which is why
I'm not even
close as an
adult it's like a that's the
double-edged butter knife of
psychedelics is that like you realize oh
life could be this amazing and then you
got to come back to this [__] existence
and you're like oh man I have to eat fun
fungus again to feel that way but I had
a situation like that on mushrooms in
Denver there was this old guy that to
hang out at this bar a concert L out and
they all went into this bar and there's
just a bunch of drunk [__] they take
this old dude's seat it he always sat
there he got up to take a leak comes
back he's like wants his seat back the
guy's like make me get out of your seat
and he's being a real prick to this guy
yeah and everyone in the bar is like
That's Mike he's here all the time
whatever and they're the guy's like I
don't give a [__] so his girlfriend goes
give the guy a seat back and he pushes
his girlfriend and now we're all kind of
like yo like you don't do that you get
one more of those
when this song ends you get one more in
this
song and then he got up and kind of was
like you know who's going to make me
like he just was a drunk like bull in a
china shop and I felt like the mushroom
confidence and strength just my my Souls
like just went down to like the core of
the earth and I'm like you can't budge
me yeah you were like snicked
Sni serious I understand what you mean
with that exit like you're in front of
every move like I saw the guy coming at
me and I'm like he's going to come this
way like I could just feel it and I just
like zoned right in and just one shot
and I got kicked out but they were like
come back tomorrow and we'll buy you all
your drinks and whatever but I'm like
yeah I had to do the right thing and
stand up for [__] yeah but I don't
like fighting on psychedelics it was
terrible but it was like this thing of
kind of like I have to do this mushrooms
is a different Beast too because you're
also so much more sensitive to
everything and you you are hurt by
somebody's opposition like you're like
come on man like this is not what I'm
about is that what way feel pretty much
but I mean that was me just jumping too
like that I wasn't pushed or anything I
just saw my friend in trouble and just
kind of ran and also ecstasy is
synthetic so it's like you don't know
what's in it you're probably eating like
a I mean God who knows what I put in
hindsight I'm just like I get it but
like you know all natural something all
natural I used to do I used to do all my
drugs while drinking like always
everything was while drinking and now
that I don't and I just do drugs you
know like I don't know like I don't want
to ruin a mushroom exp I don't really
drink anymore I mean I I I don't like
not drink but the way I drink now
is it it is 100% changed fully I I I do
not let myself get drunk I almost can't
like like I I almost like I'm like it
takes too many and I'm not like I'm not
I'm not going to commit to like four
five BS four five shots in a certain
amount of time and then just get effed
up and then and then have to like have
the hang over it just doesn't make any
sense to me like it's so much to consume
and I'm like I got to get it's like you
know I'll have a glass of wine with
dinner I have a beer a barbecue couple
beers but I just don't do it any it's
like it actually doesn't appeal to me
like I I don't if I could get the like a
feeling of a nice Buzz without having to
do all the work maybe but nowadays I'm
just like it doesn't appeal The Hangover
is such a deter I mean I I hav I'll be 5
years in December no drinking that's
great and it's it's more I mean I I quit
when my wife was pregnant but it also I
you know now zoomed out it's like oh I
was not doing it in a healthy way I was
I was reliant on it I was you abusing it
all that stuff so but the deterrent of
like you know even a skankfest I'm
hanging around and everybody's drinking
I'm like part of me is like I wish I
could but you know then later you see
what happens with alcohol and then the
next day you get the look at also what
happens and mys as you age it's like it
got dark dude because the anxiety and
depression that stemmed from it is like
brutal like I'm I'm probably now 5 years
no cigarettes and I would smoke packs
when I drank like I would light one
right off the other and it was just that
even that quantifies your hangover like
tenfold the cigarette hangover you wake
up feeling like you sucked on pennies
all night yeah like it's just that's not
what I thought you were going to
say pennies was not like my my first
five gu you could remove an n and an e
for them for
me yeah cuz I would have felt loudy that
one
yeah what do you mean it felt like on
pennies I don't even know what that
means metallic mouth like a cigarette
mouth like you know like I don't know if
oh the worst your hair your clothes just
but just like this like yeah like a
gross coming too and you're like like
lifting your head like 1,000 lbs
smelling tobacco cigarette you it your
nose and you're like just smell absolute
worst ripe cigarettes I think about the
amount of like the whole idea of
pregaming like getting cocked before
going out to bars how about waiting
online on the sidewalk for sometimes 30
minutes to an hour to be l in to go up
to the bar to wait 20 minutes to get a
drink yeah and just giving giving them
money giving them money just getting
bounced around spilling half of it I cuz
sometimes I'll be driving in the city
and there's like a line outside of place
and I always say the same like I I don't
know who I was that that appealed to me
you know what it is you're single and
you you you you know you want to mangle
you
I remember there being a feeling of like
I cannot miss a Thursday night a Friday
night a Saturday night and then I
remember like the first time like
staying home on a Friday night and being
like oh you can miss a Friday night and
then it was like I missed every Friday
night after that D dude M I didn't even
I haven't thought of this all making
plans like every week there was the
process of it would begin and you'd be
like who's doing wats Friday who wants
to do wats Saturday and it's like I want
to go here oh and I heard this this is
good and then finally someone and that's
where we're going that day and that's
where we're going this day and that was
every weekend for years like what are we
doing this weekend like I can't even you
know as a comic now that we're on the
road we we like I don't have the days
don't mean anything to me a Saturday the
only thing I get on a Saturday and a
Sunday because I still also have a
normal like a like a traditional job as
well with the with the non-stand up
stuff is that I have less anxiety that
if I don't do anything I'm I I feel bad
about
Saturday which kind of sucks yeah I
actually like that though because it
makes every day a weekend day right kind
of what stand is
yeah stri there's things I like about it
and things I don't you know but part of
the anticipation and fun of Friday and
Saturday is certainly stripped but it
does kind of elevate the fun of every
other night dude how about before like
texting right you had to get on the
phone so I used to go out you I had a
group of guys there was like 20 of us
you know and and so you had to get on
the phone did you oh I talked to him he
said he wants to do this but I talked to
him he said him and him already doing
that or not going to do that they want
to do this and hang you would have to
call it was like a a hotline and then
you'd leave for the night and just trust
that they'd be there no we we would do
one of two things there was meet up
points for all the cars so it's like oh
also who's driving right so if there was
four car loads my friends were like
everyone everyone's driving and we're
not planning any
contingency we used to park at someone's
house or we would meet it would just be
like all right this is our car load
that's your car load we we'll go and
we'll meet we park and then we would get
to the and then also was that whole
thing is we also then broke off into
twos even if we were with 10 people
because they wouldn't let more than like
two guys in together and we used to wait
about 5 minutes between each other get
the things we yeah
they so they would be in a pizza place
on the corner and then we'd all be in
there and we'd go like literally like we
were sending like troops you know like
we'll go go in five you guys are going
in five all right so and then and then
so then no one would no one would know
the door guy would know that we were all
together did you have like your pre
that's how you had to do it did you guys
have and if someone wore something I'm
so sorry no go ahead go ahead if someone
I was just going to say like they they
they they [__] you around with the
dress code so like if you had you went
out with like 10 guy or whatever and
then one guy wore something wrong and he
couldn't get in that guy had to choose
whether to leave alone or we we split in
half or we all leave and then you got to
go through that process again I remember
one time my friend Jimmy he wore like
too much of a an athletic shoe uhuh and
we didn't know what to do we ended up
going into a hardware store he bought
black electrical tape and taped his
shoes up and black electrical tape got
back online and the guy's eye didn't go
there again and got in and he wore black
electrical tape on his shoes the whole
night wow I cuz now it's like you could
go to the Oscars and sneakers we've
completely won back the system it's
really great I I thank Adam s for it
really going to Red Carpet Events with
like
boxers remember we were going into a
place as adult and a buddy of mine was
wearing like a trucker hat like a night
it wasn't like a baseball like a Yankee
hat it was like you know whatever v d
wasn't wasn't a was it a Von D no I
don't think so but he um the guy stopped
him and he goes you can't come in
wearing that hat and guy walks in with a
fedora right by him and he goes what
about him and he goes That's a fashion
hat he goes he can wear that in that's a
fashion hat so funny and it was just
like oh my God God I love to just see
the guy that chose the Fedora like win
you know what I
mean cuz you know I said this before I
said this before it's like three type
three people can wear a fedora okay
black people children and Justin
Timberlake that's that's the only white
guy that could pull it off
but like other than that if you're in a
fedora and you're listening look you're
out there Fedora people for sure most
likely all your friends are lying to you
yeah right all of you there's you just
something about a fedora you just can't
pull off no unless you're someone that's
like fashionable yeah if you don't if
you don't if you if fashion is not life
to you you can't pull it off no you
can't had nobody says anything to that
guy no you know God forbid God forbid
one of your friends came with a fedora
we would we we would say something I
would say something I would set it on
fire they they might we did we actually
at the at skang Fest at the Brooklyn
bizaar we set Rich voss's Fedora on fire
well you're talking to a lifer he's a
fedora lifer I've seen him in a I've
seen his head twice I've known him for
15 years he's got his bathroom Fedora
but something about it works I mean he
wore enough that it be became sutured to
his head like if he was an action figure
it would come
attached all of his finger ornament
Rings totally make it work everything
everything is is I've always I I was on
the road with with gate and we went into
like a men's store like a like a men's
clothing store he likes to go to those
like you know but I was looking at hats
cuz I'd love to have a hat that I could
pull off that's not just like a baseball
hat or a trucker hat and I've tried so
hard to find other I can't do it like
the the the Scully hat that like Q will
wear I I just look like a [__] dummy
in all hats and I just wish I could find
one that would work he looks good in a
pork pie hat like tot can you do can you
text me if you get this the picture of
you in that Indiana Jones hat please
right away I'm I'm going on the podcast
and I I I got to tell the story about
what
happened listen Dr Squatch I love their
soap they sent a box of it to me and I
was like it smells like Christmas in
here it was it's the best smelling soap
I've ever had I use it I've bought it
I've bought into it myself um I buy the
soap I use my own discount code because
I'm like I love this soap I've been
using it now for about six months and
it's amazing guys girls everyone's GNA
say you're smelling
good Dr Squatch the difference with them
is they have high performance natural
products they are 98% natural B Corp
certified which is a big thing in the
soap world no harmful ingredients and
they have you looking and smelling your
best so right now all the the the this
is Dr Squat soap to me is the best one
of the best holiday gifts you can get
because if you buy three soaps and get
three if you buy three soaps you will
get three soaps for free that's a $28
savings it's like getting each bar for
$4 so you buy three soaps and you get
three soaps for free 28 bucks in savings
offer only valid for new customers and
free shipping folks free shipping one of
Dr squatch's founding missions is to
encourage men to pay attention to the
ingredients they use on their body okay
so the featured products in the buy
three get three free offer in the buy
three get three free offer are cool
fresh aloe soap pinear soap fresh fall
soap bayum soap wood barrel Bourbon soap
Birchwood Bree soap and those I mean
just you could just tell just by reading
them how good it smells I mean I I feel
like I smell better I I I'm smelling all
these smells at once I feel like I'm
having a strug
right now Dr Squatch is offering my
listeners a huge savings on our hey babe
listeners all new customers will get
three bars three bar soaps plus free
shipping with any purchase of three bars
all you got to do is go to drsquatch.com
heab to receive this buy three get three
free offer okay it is literally too good
to pass up so just go to drsquatch.com D
RSQ a t c h /h buy three soaps get three
free it is time to get all the daily
routine Essentials you'll need to start
feeling good and smelling like a man
today listen good health starts with
good habits and quip which I'm holding
right here makes it Easy by delivering
all the Oral Care Essentials you need to
take care of your mou these are the
mints right here I use these mints all
the time they got my breath smelling
fresh everybody comments how good my
breast smells now it used to smell awful
now it smells amazing because of Quip
they also have the one of the electronic
toothbrushes I've ever had in my life
anything you need for your mouth quip
does it it's awesome they have the timed
Sonic vibrations with 30- second pulses
to guide a dentist recommended TW minute
clean it's lightweight Sleek design for
adults and kids no wires or bulky
charger to weigh you down it is a
multi-use travel cover that doubles as a
mirror mount for Less clutter skip the
batteries and Sapp it to healthy habits
with the new rechargeable electric
toothbrush all the features of the
original quip Plus one magnetic charge
Powers up to three months of brushing
these mints every time you pop in these
new mints that I'm holding right here
you'll be caring for your mouth inside
and out bold mint flavors keep your
breath confidently fresh and you'll get
a boost of vitamin D that's what's
different about these that's huge
especially me you know I'm white I
barely get any sun I get my vitamin D
from quip mints the gump prevents
cavities and freshens breath when chewed
for 20 minutes after eating sugar-free
and has too friendly aotol with zero
calories SL travel ready dispenser it's
available in five colors it really is
awesome if you go to getquip.com
right now you're going to get 20% off
any electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flosser that's 20%
off any electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flosser at
getquip.com
heab it is
gq.com quip the goodh habits
company I digress
yeah you know I'll tell you this though
you know those Goran Brothers stores
like the hat stores like that that
they're actually like real hats like
they they'll pay a couple hundred bucks
it's like what they wore in like the 50s
when I go in there I secretly do long to
be able to wear not a Cheesy Fedora but
like there was one like dark green with
a band with a little little little like
kind of not a feather like a call it
macaroni but like a like a fashionable
feather you know what I mean like a guy
that used to shoot dice in the alley
type of thing kind of and I and I always
wish that I could do it but I know
better and sometimes I'll put it on in
the store you know and then I'll have
like a 30- second moment with myself
where I consume it and I say look this
is you and this is your dream but then
you put Then I then I put it back and
that's it so one time I bought that
month I bought that hat I bought that
hat and I spent like like 160 bucks with
tax on that thing and I was like it was
I had lost a bunch of weight okay I was
I was and I was a summer and I was tan
and I I I I was I was wearing a white v-
T-shirt no okay yeah so but but don't
get me wrong so my my girlfriend my
girlfriend was encouraging me to take
more fashion risks time because in
college I was known for that believe it
or not fashion risk yes kidding they
called me retro because I I threw
together all old clothes and outfits I
went to school you're Ahad of your time
I do have phot bring I will bring photos
that's amazing yeah I went to school in
St John's which is in St Island and then
no dress like that so luckily I wasn't
treated as an outcast I was just treated
as oh that's the guy that goes to New
York City you know I
me have you heard of it was it tops and
bottoms or was it just like I I wore I
wore a seafoam green leisure suit to
college one day yeah but it wasn't
always like that I mixed and match I did
old and new but you know when I was
feeling it I wore that leisure suit I
wore a leisure suit to my eighth grade
dance intend like because I also was
taking fashion risks I thought I was
funny I thought I mean I didn't wait
till you had the wherewithal to take a
fashion risk in eth grade yeah I had
like the the big collar the the jacket
was almost like a like a shimmery red
black that changed like in whichever
direction you looked at it I had the
white and black like kind of tap shoe
looking St pants I was fresh look like
he in a you have a picture of that I I
think I do well I have a picture of
myself and my wife at the eighth grade
dance both and I'm in that outfit that's
amazing if you got it send it to him
we uh that's why I'm such a fan of the
winter cuz you could Rock like a knit
hat like a beanie that's all I have man
beanies are tough on beanies are tough
on bald guys because you could just tell
like you could it's so hugged to the
head you don't have one little you don't
even have a little cuz when I wear a
beanie I like a little flip of
hair a little condom you
yeah look it does look like a receptical
if I wear if I wear like a fitted hat
it's I have just like it's just make a
reservoir is that what it is yeah what
a a resir I said receptical I loved when
I had I once had a beanie with a with a
brim that was super remember uh no
that's that's that's that's fish concert
all the way that's a fish concert all
the way that's like a black gauge in
your ear stretching it out too dude I
don't have I or an American Eagle Ed or
something like that yeah totally but I
don't I I just wish that's like Seth
Green in can hardly wait totally exactly
yeah I definitely have a hacky sack and
a [__] this is how fashion forward
Fel is that's a hat from cartoons that's
yed Sam wears that hat that's not even a
fedora it's a it's a cartoon hat and he
walks around with that and people are
like should I get that hat yeah toally
should I wear that hat he's wearing this
thing looks like if you said make the
silliest hat that you could make and no
one would wear and he put it on his head
it's it it looks like the Hat in
cartoons when if if you were a guy and
then you had a guy in a smaller guy in
here that you were trying to sneak and
and then you would open it and the other
guy would hop out that's how hard that
is twice the length of his face and he
walks around and he owns that [__] he's
also so good looking he can kind of make
any any fashion Choice work like Michael
Jordan tried to bring back the Hitler
stash unsuccessfully but I think farel
could actually do it they would call it
a chap if they did yeah they would call
it a chap so I bought that hat and you
know honestly I think my I think my if
she wasn't with me I I remember buying
it thinking like I think that she'll
appreciate what I did here and uh like I
said I was tan I was thinner I was
probably only around like 200 which is
for me is is where I look I look really
thinned out then I'm 20 over that right
now to give you a little context um and
I bought it and I was like I'm going to
do this and I know when I do it I I got
to really be wearing the Hat I can't let
the Hat Wear me
because then I be I will be mocked
roundly I'll be ridiculed and then I
will never live down that hat sure and I
was I got the Gusto to do it and I was
in between shows on the road I bought it
in San Francisco and I had a flight to
Sacramento and I accidentally got off
the plane and left it in the overhead
compartment so it was never meant to be
and I've never even looked at another
Fedora in my life it was a sign it was a
sign that if I would have wore that
thing it might have my whole life might
have went a different way it may you you
never know what could be the thing the
Catal
flown back to San Francisco and stayed
there like follow your box was it in a
hat box no no I've seen people put boxes
are awesome they really kind of are and
here's the thing about that hat here's
the thing about that hat I put my
someone has it right now nobody threw
that hat out that was a brand new
beautiful $160 amazing to think of the
life of that hat like where is that hat
I always think about that it's somewhere
I always think about it love there's
just some guy on the tarmac waving in a
I mean it's been 10 years let's say an
older guy took it right and he wore it
for 10 years and then he gave it to his
son or something that hat could really
be having a real life of its own oh yeah
totally it is there's no chance that
it's not yeah one time my little dog he
was a Toy Fox Terrier on November 7th he
ran away off the leash where my dad was
walking him and we never saw him again
and the two things I always wonder about
is where's that Fedora and where is Remy
Martin my my my my dog I said please God
someone scoop him up cuz he couldn't
survive element He was this big you know
I'm thinking about you if you're out
there buddy I mean you're dead now
natural causes but check her hat she's
wearing like an old like uh like Dutch
Master's box I feel like anytime you see
a woman like this in the crowd you kind
of know she's going to be a problem yeah
I mean this is this is you feeling
yourself too much as a matter of fact a
lot of women you know there's the Fedora
guy is like one in a 100 he's there yeah
yeah but the woman the women who will
Who will think that they look good in
the goofy [__] looking hat is like 50
out of 100 like if you go to like brunch
or like some type of a christening or
like it's not even Easter dude if you go
to a club anything there's a 50/50 ratio
of women in goofy
hats they have gangs the old pulling
that [__] off and they're not no they're
not yeah that's the male Fedora for most
of you I hate the one with the brim
where like the hair goes in it and it's
like kind of like a it's almost like a
cap but it's like it holds the hair over
here oh yeah have the roster right it's
like a roster one but not
that the one with the the huge like
thing every drunk white Heckler wearing
that [__] or the or the female in the
in the in the traditional Fedora you're
not pulling it you're not Paula Abdul no
you know in in in a in a music video you
know where she's in a like a tuxedo kind
of like a spandex tuxedo that she has a
cane I buy it you know this is she's
doing she's doing choreography she
throws standa go like that you know what
I mean this has a purpose to it you know
what I mean like you're making me
realize a real problem I have in my
marriage is I'm very supportive of my
wife's hat
choices oh my God I I was describing
your wife I'm sorry no no no she doesn't
she doesn't wear just whenever she wears
whatever not not there are women that
pull it off I don't know which one your
like a newsy cap or something like that
just to celebrate my Irish heritage and
she'll undress me for hours just like
just be like I can't believe who gave
you the
the confidence yeah if it's something
you don't put on a lot it's it stands
out now if you forged ah head and wore
that hat I do every time oh yeah I wear
to be honest her her dislike of it
drives me to wear it for maybe a week or
two
completely with his haircut
b as soon as you speak against does he
wear it
his where do you guys fall on
Beret the Beret oh I mean the Beret is
right in there the Beret is right in
there the is's cousin yeah I mean
honestly if you're not selling French
bread yeah you know honestly you better
be [__] playing in
a yeah you know I it's got to be perfect
I mean look at you you you Googled Beret
men and the these 40 images that came up
first not one guy not one guy is pulling
it off I mean I mean you look so stupid
this guy with the feather in his cap he
looks like with a quill pen yeah what
the guy next to him how good is that how
good does he look right to the left the
other one yeah this guy I mean that
looks like an ADT for Kenneth Cole or
something you know I don't think he's
real a real guy I think that's an
advertisement yeah look at this [__]
idiot right here seriously he's got on a
it's like a chef hat yeah that sucks he
sells um if you're not in a neighborhood
watch take the Beret off you know what I
mean take it off if you're wearing it
for a good cause if I'm supposed to
identify you emergency wear the Beret
it's a beacon it's a maroon Beacon but
if you're not going to help me if [__]
goes down get out here just get the out
you're totally right you can't wear
something that has a silent
letter it's not for
us we at Spike rocking one for sure
you're you're 100% right but but but so
so who are these people surrounded with
that they take or or or do they have a
gene that is to be commended that we
don't or I don't have
happiness but meer used to have an old
bit about this but it's it it's great
where he like saw somebody with a
captain's hat in the audience and just
like kind of nodded to it or made fun of
it a little bit and the person was like
oh and he's like well you're wearing a
[__] Captain hat like he's like I
understand you have to wear a certain
outfit to attract a certain type of
woman but
yeah and it's true that like guys that
dress like that aren't wearing it for us
they're wearing it so they can get a
girl who reads poetry at the bar right
you know right 100% yeah that's their
whole thing what do a what do a hats for
bald guys bring up because you know it
is a a thing and I'm sure I'm not the
only one now
see a turtle shell dude look at the
first no the top list is is that
multicolor hat with the propeller on
straight up howdy dude dude also you
can't wear that Prada hat that is truly
just circumcising your own head oh
really does look like a reservoir tip
that is so stupid that one was a wear
that truly truly if you like are a long
shoran yeah yes that's when you wear
that look at that a hat with hair built
in that's dope that's amazing that's
cool I'd rock that I don't even like
like what are the bucket hats now that
are kind of coming back like they're
coming back but again I had one when I
was a kid but it's just I don't know I
didn't even like it then I I
embarrassingly wear will wear a bucket
hat on on occasion golfing mostly
because it it covers everything so
that's that's mostly but that's that's L
Cool J and Paddington Bear and that's
Paddington Bear yes that's 100% dude L
Cool J and padic to Bear the only two
that can wear it I did I went through I
went through a phas uh 98 I wore a
bucket hat yeah I had a Cordo bucket did
yeah Brown cord American Eagle bucket
hat mine was from American
but it wasn't uh I got too excited for
that oh no this no oh my God friends
forever yeah no I remember in '98
because uh everyone was wearing them and
I had a summer house with friends and I
have pictures of myself in it and yeah
you did you change any of your style
during the pandemic because I like my
bucket hat phase started during the
pandemic I also started buying vintage
starter jackets and then I also started
wearing tie eye almost exclusively I got
tie-dye in my motation now and I have a
starter jacket as well bucket hat I
won't do but i h honestly I I I think
you could pull off a bucket hat no you
have a flavor and a swag that works with
that it's weed I think I think if if you
are known for marijuana bucket hats they
don't necessarily look good but it makes
sense yeah but no I if I didn't know you
smoked weed you still present yourself I
see a I I I see a swag with you oh nice
you have a nice beard you have a nice
beard and you're you have a nice beard
and you're thin that oh that's a great
hat yeah that is that's I mean that's
One Step before you put the helmet on
your head with the two beers in the
straw that's what I should be wearing
kind of you know what if they expanded
the the the circumference the diameter
whatever you want to call it it's kind
of a genius idea if you're in the rain
if you could
wear to carry things look at that who
what is that what I've never seen that
in my life it's like a metallic Swan
that's awesome I like those ones the The
Umbrellas that kind of come around you
too yeah totally oh yeah yeah Mak a
force that's pretty cool that's like a
tent that's a baby tent on that guy's
head yeah where do you wear that on
Safar though like why is it here's my
problem with
umbrellas you look like an
idiot if you you take an umbrella out
with you right and then the rain is such
that it's raining but come on yeah you
can walk without that umbrella so come
on blower the umbrella you almost feel
like yeah you feel like there's you're
in the minority most people do not have
an umbrella you're one of like not a lot
and so it looks idiotic right but then
the flip started half the other people
are like it's raining and you hold an
umbrella you idiot when you're too cool
for an umbrella so I never know during a
light
fall if what I'm supposed to do it's a
hard it's a hard thing and also when you
have the umbrella and it's not open you
almost feel inclined at a stop light or
in an in an elevator to be like I
thought it was going to be raining more
today that's why I brought this you have
to like you know like you have to like
but I'm with you on that I'm like do you
carry it with you I I now don't even
carry umbrellas I'm pure rain jacket
pullover so I have like a really light
saf your shoes and and the knee down
really yeah I mean if it's raining or if
rain is in the forecast I'll wear
beaters anyway so it's like I'm not
wearing anything I love a rain car I
have three yeah yeah yeah I still have
one from when I was 15 and I went to
Ireland for gaic football and it says
like Ireland trip 2000 or whatever and I
wear that my rain coat that I wear so
you have the same body the same yeah if
not a yeah I'm I'm a little bit uh
bigger bro 6ot when I was like 15 I
think I I'm definitely I was a twig I
was puess and six foot tall when I was
like 15 years old yeah that image never
never went to my mind in my life I had
no armpit hair till junior year of of
high school and no like real pubes until
then either so I had like I mean my dick
was developing at a at a regular pace
but uh but everything else it looked
like I was just a
baby wild it was weird my poor son
damn suspenders let's talk about
it I can't the suspender is the
suspender is basically right in the same
wheelhouse as the Fedora I think it's
slightly more acceptable yeah but you
got to look a certain way and you got to
be wearing a certain hip outfit you got
to be thin and tall or ripped in order
to wear it like like Jack from Titanic
like that or danito in taxi like there's
no like you're not in the middle you're
not riding the middle I had to put on I
okay full disclosure when I was in uh my
retro phase I wore um I remember wearing
black suspenders with these dis like
fully vintage Levi distressed jeans that
were ripped all over with like a long
sleeve cuz it was also a grung era so it
was I wore a long sleeve white shirt and
and I had on like Vans and I and it
worked I do believe it worked I believe
it worked I don't know if no one told me
you were also in an incubus cover band
at the time no it wasn't that Vibe it
was a Vibe I just whatever I maybe I
maybe I look like a [__] I don't know
but not that long ago though I had to
wear suspenders for a tuxedo for an
event and uh you know the suspenders
they take on a whole different life if
they're not just going straight now oh
yeah you know so when they go suspend
and then they go on your stomach and all
then the suspenders are more like
Racing Stripes yeah they're like check
me out over here like look at this show
like it's like a topographical
map it really isut so I mean that's
tough too you can pull off suspenders I
can yeah my father cannot he's a bigger
Irish guy so it would like complete like
he you know burst something he like big
Tom Callahan basically at that point
Tommy boy's dad everybody had the
[__] big yeah you had to wear them on
IJ too I did have to wear them on cuz
they were I was supposed to be a hack
comic you a fish tie
you were a fish TI a lot of people they
they Cho that up and put it online and a
lot of people think that's my stand up
and I'm bombing and everyone's like look
look at well they'll reference it
they're like I'm not going to come see
you that bomb they put I'm like dude I
was literally I was dressed like a um a
Catskills com I had big shoulder pads
out had a fish tie and suspenders and I
was like women huh like it was just like
and they believe that that's what I it
was so great I love that well you know
so that's where we that went fast that
did yeah can I ask you guys a question
serious if you were bald and I let my
hair grow a little bit during the
pandemic and I grow thick in the back
nothing up top and then I have like a
shower curtain like one you got I look
like the critic like I literally it
looks like Fraser crane in the back at
what age am I is it cool for me to just
you look like boss like baby boss or
something yeah you know how they have
that little tust right here coming out
like but nothing up top but I got to
like spaghetti Fork it at what age is it
like cool to just let it go I'm I hate
hate shaving my head uh never never I'm
always shaving my head I know I don't
think I have the I don't have you'll
just look like big ear and McCracken
like that'll be a tough no oh cool
November 9th you can watch my special
don't let me down at premieres on
YouTube and uh right now you can get it
if you can't wait at 800p gm.com pay
what you want model uh you can go to
Mike pho.com for tickets subscribe to
the YouTube Mike phoa and uh my podcast
Comes A Time with otal Burbridge as well
I I know we but I can't recommend going
to see these guys enough I appreciate
you man yeah absolutely guys uh in
November just really quickly I'm in
Peoria Rockford Cedar Rapids Springfield
duth Appleton rockchester Davenport and
Elkart Indiana all in November December
1st and second is the taping at the Vic
theater my standup comedy special and uh
I have no idea because we're doing this
ahead of time if there are tickets left
uh it's selling strong I hope there
aren't but if there are grab them and if
you have a ticket you are eligible I'm
going to pick one ticket out of those
four shows to Florida New York and come
to the set of Impractical Jokers
everything on savalan comedy.com love
you guys thank you I'll tell you this
one s sorry I forgot about that Chrissy
has a full oh coctober of dates this is
coming out in November check his site
Christy comedy.com for all those dates
I'll be in New England with him so
that'll beun he definitely has November
dates I'm sure because he's all over the
road totally um yeah so so so mer James
Murray is this on my on my show um and
we we convinced him uh
one time that he he put on a hat that
all I could describe is it's
basically if he if his life was all
about
safaris and he he he came to us and he
he we saw him looking in the mirror in
the store and like we saw him trying to
convince himself yeah you know and he
and but the thing about myrr is and God
bless him but he sometime is uh a bit
too cocky you know like you know and I
saw him he was like tipping the like a
ston hat right it's a ston and he's like
looking at it he's touching he's like
he's making faces and we're like oh my
God please please ask us if you should
buy this and he turned around he comes
he goes what do you guys think we were
like dude like you you look good like
like that like you you are pulling that
off like and he's like yeah and we like
I'm like dude I wouldn't tell you if I
didn't think so dude it you have the
right head for it his head is a size I
swear to God of an actual PE yeah it's
he has a small hat it's a stepson hat
it's crazy dude it just it looks like he
looks like he put a a [__] hat on a
straw and uh a Q-tip and uh and we got
him to buy it and he subsequently wore
it around and then he didn't find out
until the pandemic we'd had this show
called dinner party where we all ate
dinner together live and talked about
stuff and that came up and he went and
grabbed it and we we admitted to him on
live on TV that live live and we're like
dude we lied to you about that you look
so
bad and you've been wearing it for years
and he was like no you're lying like
dude dude the fact that you believed
that you look good in that like that you
were like we had to tell you that you
look good because you're you're you are
blind you know what I mean you did not
pull that off this I'll show you guys
but obviously pimp uh will put it up on
and he's the best he's the best sport
about it but I want you also look at his
demeanor in this picture he's literally
trying to be so like
like dude that is outstanding he's
trying to give a look that will at least
make the hat look a little better like
he's trying to own it he's trying to
look like the guy in Red Dead
100% Indiana it just doesn't work you
know you're at that at the point you're
a guy in your 30s you're going to walk
around in a ston hat you know and a
wooden boat
yeah yeah at the time he also was dating
someone who was uh who bought his
wardrobe for him and their style was
very uh slacks uh dress shoe like a nice
Capezio that Michael Jackson used to
wear he used to wear a button down with
suspenders and he was known for the bow
tie and so we would go on stage together
on tour I'm in what you wear every
single day so Q Joe does a little bit of
like uh I'm going to wear a button down
I'm going to match it to my sock I'm
going to match it to my watch guy and
then Murray would come on literally
looking like he was you know like
literally like he was going to tell you
guys about how good this Carnival is
going to be and he got so people started
to buy him bow ties because we would do
meet and greets bring gifts and he was
known as the bow tie guy there was a
point in his life he had hundreds of bow
ties okay and then one day he walks in
with a wooden bow tie W bow tie I
remember this we told him it looked
great as well because we were like
that's it right there nobody has that
nobody does that you're pulling that off
and this this idiot I love you with all
my heart this guy not he's not an idiot
but like this was so fun for us because
he was walking around in the STS and hat
with a wooden bow TI with a with with
confidence and that's even better for us
it just brought me so much joy M thank
you and you know what honestly if you
believe you are pulling it off then you
have nothing to worry about because you
should believe what you feel and what
you feel as you pulled it off and maybe
other people looked at you and you had
that confidence in they thought it too I
did not you know so and I
knew you well this is part of the
reasons I love him that he will wear a
wooden bow tie on stage and he will wear
a STS and hat because you know that
brings me so much joy I love that so
anyway you looked idiotic I'm sorry we
kept it from you we've done so much to
him we used to when he used to get up
from a table at a dinner and sign his
check he used to always get up first and
hastily and we'd always open it change
the tip we did that for years we had a
game where we could see who cost him the
most money cuz we knew he didn't check
his credit cards so we would we would
literally have a tally of who cost him
the most money when he got up and walked
away and that didn't come out till like
years later we cost him thousands
thousands and to his credit he took it
in stride Mur is such a good sport with
all that stuff anyway yeah so uh that
was so much fun thank you guys when
super fast I love you come back anytime
thanks everybody uh see you next week
peace don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesit take to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey babe